la représenter par franchement oui je
pense oui il a été l'artisan du blocage
pour
des artisans principaux du blocage et je
pense même que c'est un des artisans du
fait que la gauche soit en miettes et
comme elle l'est comme elle l'a été pour
la première pour la présidentielle ou
par les clarifications vous dit qu'il
s'en aille c'est ce que disait olivier
faure il ya quelques jours qu'ils
partent donc que bernard cazeneuve par
exemple 10 en cas d'accord moi je je
quitterais parti socialiste qui est une
partie des militants ou des cartes
qu'ils s'en aillent pour vous ça fait
partie de cette qualification c'est pas
un problème c'est même quelque chose
qu'une page est avéré qui reste c'est
mais s'ils veulent partir qu'il parte à
un moment et ils peuvent pas tout
bloquer ils peuvent pas tout bloquer
bloquer une renaissance de la gauche ils
ne peuvent pas bloquer une recomposition
à gauche et on peut pas imaginer que ce
soit la déchéance de nationalité les
lois travail etc qui est un droit de
veto sur ce qui se passe à gauche
aujourd'hui ce serait injuste ce serait
pas à la hauteur des enjeux et par
ailleurs je rappelle quand même que
l'objectif principal de cette union
c'est que jean luc mélenchon soit
premier ministre et que surtout on
protège la vie des français deux des
réformes libérales d' emmanuel macron
c'est un enjeu est vraiment il ya des
gens qui vont manger ou pas manger il ya
des gens qui vont travailler ou pas
travailler à cause de ces réformes
libérales donc là maintenant il faut
vraiment concours à cet accord c'était
fait parmi les choses qui bloque ya
évidemment la répartition des
circonscriptions ça ça fait partie des
négociations ses fans le disait vous en
avez obtenu une centaine est ce que vous
en êtes prêt vous êtes prêts ont laissé
certaines au parti socialiste pour que
l'accord se fasse mais nous on a déjà
signé donc là on
enfin déjà signale pas sur un accord oui
mais après ça c'est les filles au ps de
se mettre d'accord c'est ce que j'avais
dit au
négociateur chez nous je leur avais dit
il photo p en premier ou à la baisse je
pense que c'est sa passion l'a fait
confortable et c'est ce qu'on a fait et
je pense que c'est très spéciaux n'est
pas d'accord une fille née entre le
parti socialiste et les autres forces de
gauche est-ce que la corde ensemble a
encore du sens est-ce que vous avez
négocié avec le je pense mais je suis
sûr qu'il y aura un accord et d'ailleurs
je salue le travail incroyable qui est
fait par olivier faur qui quand même
tient la barre malgré les vents
contraires malgré les secousses malgré
les coups de pression malgré les coups
de menton et respect à lui quoi
[Musique]